Biden has made it no secret that he
wants to control the media and in Joe's
perfect world he gets to decide what's
in misinformation or not Biden taking
aim at Elon Musk and the ex-s social
media platform over that
what about what Elon Musk has done to
Twitter lowering guard rails against
misinformation does that contribute to
it yeah it does where where do people
get their news
you know they go on the internet they
they they they they go online they go
and you have no notion
whether it's true or not
but you don't Trash Talk the world's
richest man and walk away unscathed
musk's firing back at the president
saying quote the corpse in Weekend at
Bernie's literally looks more alive than
Biden
that hurt Jesse
so information is power someone said
that yes don't remember who Dom DeLuise
and
and so he's controlled information for
decades and
didn't the New York Times and NBC say
there were wmds in Iraq I mean didn't
all of these networks say that kova
didn't come from a lab so his side does
not have a monopoly on the truth and the
internet doesn't either but what the
internet does is allow access to
information to regular people just like
the Protestant Reformation with the
printing press all of a sudden the
Catholic Church can't say what's in the
Bible because everybody can read the
Bible for themselves so they splintered
off and formed their own church same
things happening now you have the
mainstream media is the filter for
whatever happens and we don't need a
filter anymore because we can go on and
we can read affidavits ourselves and we
can listen to people like Greg yes on
Twitter who's usually right yes all the
time almost all the time Stephanie's
talking about my hair okay so Katie
Biden says that musk is to blame for
lowering the guard rails and yet this
president makes up outright lies every
speech and interview he gives I mean
that being said shouldn't we be flagging
his statements as well well uh yes first
I saw on the internet that your hair is
real so I know that that's true thank
you yes just fact checking that real
quickly just to make sure you're going
to be okay I'm saying it's real it's
just not his own
well
I've done drugs before yeah that's true
um
you cannot underestimate how dangerous
this what they call the censorship
industrial complex from the government
With Private Industry actually is and
the Biden Administration continues to
try to take factual information and bury
it and we don't have enough time to go
through the list but think about all the
things that the government censored
during the coveted pandemic about the
Border about the war in in the past that
has resulted in these huge consequences
for the country and for people
everywhere and you have a president
who's now continuing to Advocate after a
court has told him that your agencies
are not allowed to talk to Big Tech
because you are censoring Americans and
violating their civil liberties through
the first amendment he wants to continue
to do that despite being told no
multiple times and that is why it's so
essential that people like Elon Musk are
out there with these big platforms and
allowing people to disagree and have a
debate about information that is
published don't you agree Jessica that
you know the public is entitled to hear
what people have to say that the first
amendment is pretty much absolute except
for things like pornography and yelling
fire in a crowded theater I do but also
these social media companies are private
entities and the first amendment is
about government censorship and there
have been Republican and Democratic
administrations that have worked in
tandem with these social media companies
and if that is
stopped them from doing that the court
has said to the Biden Administration you
can't tell private companies what to say
and what not to say well they would
argue that they're just referring
they're giving their opinion
they lost and it is being evaluated I I
still remain uncomfortable and we've
talked about this before where there is
covid vaccine misinformation I'll use
the bronnie James example again who's
now successfully gone and had surgery to
fix what was wrong with him which was
not that he had had the shot it was that
he had a pre-existing condition that
affected his heart and people
immediately took that and ran with this
was because of the vaccine Elon Musk has
also dismantled the trust and safety
mechanism
at Twitter we have seen uh Justin safety
what I'm sorry listen I there I'm sure
we all get lots of nasty comments that
come at Us online I probably maybe I get
the most from this particular show I
guess and appearing here and there's I
have reported people sometimes I get up
on a Saturday morning I think you know
what I love I would love to get people
thrown off Twitter and so I'll send in
uh you know you post it and you say this
has misogynistic comments it has violent
comments it has anti-semitic comments
and there's a steep increase in saying
oh no no this is all fine and I can tell
you
you wake up on Saturdays and report
people on Twitter
if I'm having a good day go ahead Greg I
think it's I mean it's perfectly fine to
complain about the media and social
media platforms that's all I do all day
Trump built his Legend on two words fake
news but this is different because
there's a Readiness to combine agencies
and lawfare to back up their desires for
censorship they want to control the
spigot they're suing Elon Musk right now
because musk is uncancelable he's the
world's richest man he can't be cowed or
he can't be bought he's fulfilling a
role that is necessary right now because
anybody else would be destroyed the
whole point of this misinformation
Bureau was to relabel dissent as somehow
dangerous and I and while I do empathize
with you Jessica about the stuff that
you get and the and your example of the
the of the covid misinformation that's
just part of the package you're either
going to have free speech or you're not
and you can say that these are private
companies but if you were removed from
one of these companies your career could
be destroyed these are giant companies
there are things that people people make
their livelihood off of if you are
banned from Twitter you could disappear
yo and they'll always say well why don't
you make your own why don't you make
your own well good luck but my my point
is this is that this is this is not this
is about targeting people who are
different in your in their views and the
fact is Elon Musk presents a threat
because he's not a liberal that's it all
right but shouldn't these people not
post anti-semitic things or whatever
there's a lot of things people shouldn't
do yeah there's a lot man all the time
we all get that what you get
repercussions over speech what are you
gonna do I mean that's a little scary
Jessica hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else